one of the things that psychologists
talk about is is threatened egotism what
happens when someone who has a very
strong sense of ego is challenged in
some fundamental way so you could take
one of the stories I tell in the book
that I think is interesting is there's
this famous encounter between an Haleh
Merkel and Vladimir Putin and in an
attempt to intimidate her in a state
meeting he'd heard that she was afraid
of dogs and so he lets a dog come into
the room in an attempt basically to
intimidate and to scare her and so if
anima Merkel had been coming from a
place of ego and and obviously from fear
she's gonna react to this sort of petty
attempt at intimidation with perhaps an
attempt of her own with some saber
rattling with any number of these things
but instead she's got a sense of
confidence I would say instead of ego
that she's not going to react
emotionally to this she's not going to
take it as a threat to her honor it's
not gonna escalate into being more than
what it is infection ends up making a
joke about it in it it makes Putin look
like the the weaker bully in this case
but you could see how how a different
leader when this when this is revealed
when this attempt to do something is
revealed would react in a dangerous way
you could think of a that one of the
examples they use when they talk about
threatened egotism is like a gang member
whose honor is is impudent
the way that they respond is obviously
terrible for both parties involved right
they escalate a verbal you know of a
verbal wound into violence and and and
it makes a non serious situation into a
serious one and so what what I'm trying
to talk about then is is that if we have
this sensitive ego and we're able to be
wounded and instead of looking at that
wound and sort of seeing it for what it
is we have to react emotionally we have
to react we have to react to compensate
for the way that we feel that we've been
harmed it can create really dangerous
situations very quickly so it often you
you know we think ego ego is supposed to
be strength but in fact
just a sort of a veneer for a profound
weakness and and that it's the
compensation for that that creates bad
situations
there's a wonderful Bill Walsh quote
about you though he says you know ego is
when self confidence becomes arrogance
self-assertiveness becomes reckless
abandon and and and so forth you say
he's saying it's it's it's sort of past
the point of any reasonable utility
right confidence is great arrogance is
not great or Cyril Connolly's and ego
like cancer is sort of an over assertion
of cells and that's sort of what I see
ego is it's it's great to believe in
yourself the problem is when your belief
in yourself is not based on anything
real and so that's the enemy of trying
to do basically anything that requires
interacting with other people right if
you're a creative and and and you're not
able to take feedback because you're
your ego is either so strong or or
you're not able to take feedback because
you don't care what anyone thinks your
works not gonna get any better if you
don't care about your audience you don't
understand who they are and what's going
on in their life because you lack
empathy which is another symptom of you
go your work is gonna suffer if you
can't work with other people because
you're you have to be this you're
selfish you have to be the center of
attention of all times you're not going
to have a team around you so it it
basically makes anything that we're
trying to do harder than it already is